this is a human here and yes this must
be the world's smallest comic normally I
love the big experiments the big
explosions but this clip is so cool
because it's so tiny drawn on the
surface of a human hair the images were
devised and created by artist Claudia
Poole first and nano scientist Andrews
Annenberg at the Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute in New York so how in the
world did they do it normally when you
want to draw a comic you get a piece of
paper and you get a pen now the paper in
this case is one single hair and the pen
is a focused iron beam now this doesn't
work like a normal pen would work
because it doesn't deposit in fact what
it does is a stream of charged particles
are able to obliterate the surface of
the hair creating an etched effect it's
a little bit like firing atom-sized
bullets out of a really tiny gun these
atomic bullets hit the hair with so much
speed and so much energy that they break
the bonds between the atoms in the hair
itself and they kind of scratch a hole
in the surface and that's what's used to
draw these pictures it's called
sputtering but actually it's incredibly
precise while you do love the comic book
is right here I think it's this one